Come to your five or three.
Two.
Hello everybody.
And thanks for coming to the AC pod.
That's my announcer voice.
Hey everybody.
And someone's just your voice.
It's not that different all the time.
Happy thanksgiving.
So thankful for you all.
Joining us here today.
We pulled into the parking lot and there
was nobody there and I was like,
Holy Shit.
It was difficult.
I would tell you it was difficult to
come in today.
I had a big ass meal.
I could barely move,
but we did it.
We came in,
we did it.
So thank you.
So God bless.
Today's episode is sponsored by
postmates dollar shave club and Vince
Sero.
How was all of your thanksgiving?
How was your thanksgiving?
You luckily you made,
I know her food.
Yeah,
so I enjoyed some food,
but I don't like the Thanksgiving food.
You know what?
Can I make a confession?
I don't like Turkey.
It's the most boring meet imaginable and
it's like the Gamey.
It's dry usually it's just,
it's not there.
It's just now it's not a word of the
bird.
And you read it with the cranberry,
cranberry.
What else?
I know there's people at home who were
like,
yeah,
I know it's a very polarizing thing.
I don't like stuffing.
I don't like cranberry.
I don't like Turkey.
But I took Thanksgiving it to my own
hands because I said,
you know what?
I'm going to make a pot roast and I
would like to call these Ethan's
heavenly potatoes.
True cause I wanted to make sure isla
could eat and what Ethan's heavenly
mashed potatoes and let me tell you,
okay,
I'll tell you what's in it.
But that doesn't do any good because
it's all about the technique.
When people see what's in it,
they can't believe that it's going to
taste good.
Well sure.
And you should be,
you should be horrified by what I put in
it.
But that's the secret to every good
restaurants cooking,
you know what I mean?
Is that's why food at restaurants tastes
so unbelievably good.
It's because if you actually went back
there in the kitchen,
you would never have the balls to cook
food the way they do.
Like,
you know,
putting a whole stick of butter and for
like two eggs scrambled eggs,
you're like,
oh,
these scrambled eggs are amazing.
I never had my eggs.
Never tastes like this before.
There's a whole stick of butter.
So what I do is I put a whole stick of
butter and a whole block of cream shoes
for every four potatoes.
So yesterday was two.
Yeah,
there was eight potatoes to a whole
sticks of butter and two whole blocks of
cream cheese.
And I hear dad freaking out in the back,
but I'm talking,
I mean that sounds bomb,
but it is bombed Dan.
It,
it just tastes like potatoes.
It doesn't even taste crazy airy.
It's a slight,
it tastes incredible.
You can eat ham mouthfuls of mouthfuls
and little do you know that every bite
has probably 200 calories.
I love mashed potatoes is the best dish
you ever like potatoes by themselves are
already pretty unhealthy,
but then you like,
or like heavy,
heavy,
let's say.
There's just nothing really good in it I
guess.
But it's not unhealthy.
No,
I'm not a nutritionist.
I'm not even gonna claim that.
I don't make claims on this podcast
anymore.
I don't know.
What's funny,
I didn't even know that.
My name is Ethan.
I cannot confirm or deny that.
My name is Ethan,
allegedly.
Allegedly.
My name is Ethan and it was Thanksgiving
yesterday.
Don't hold me to that though.
Um,
and come the expose videos about my name
not be,
um,
anyway,
these potatoes aren't credible or hit.
I got this pressure cooker instant pot.
Have you guys heard of this?
Whole crazy,
I had two massive pot roasts.
I put in there for two hours.
I got to tell you,
nobody cared about the Turkey.
I had a pity bite just so my sister
didn't feel bad.
Your sister cooked all them bay,
not Turkey.
I know.
And that's what I'm saying.
When you came in two hours,
I pop it in,
I set it and forget it.
And all of a sudden it's a smash potato
heaven.
I care so much about smashed potatoes,
mashed potatoes,
and it's so important that they be
right.
You know,
and on all day,
but and add any,
right.
I hope you Dan,
how was your thanksgiving?
It was great.
It was really nice,
actually saw a bunch of extended family
I haven't seen in years.
So that was cool.
And uh,
yeah,
it was nice.
Good food.
You're vegetarian.
Were they able to accommodate you?
They did accommodate.
It was very nice to them.
Um,
the,
uh,
the wife of my uncle,
I guess my aunt in law,
if that's the thing.
She's a vegetarian too,
so she hooked it up.
So thank you to that.
What is,
what is the vegetarian eat on
Thanksgiving?
Uh,
well,
I mean most of the sides are vegetarian
and they,
they made sure the,
like the stuffing,
you know,
usually the stuffing isn't vegetarian,
but they made vegetarian stuffing and
you know,
the cranberries and I know you,
I know how you feel about it.
Yes.
And in Anzac,
everyone had a good time.
Everyone's happy.
Everyone's satisfied,
I hope.
Definitely.
Yeah,
it was a,
I mean,
I'm not a big fan of Turkey either,
but who is,
yeah,
no,
I mean some people like it.
We're also not fans of the pies.
So there was a bunch of Pumpkin pie and
I don't,
you know,
I don't want to offend too many people
here.
I know I'm going to start a whole new
way of,
of uh,
but I don't like Pumpkin Pie,
but Ian about it and he made a chocolate
pie.
Thank God for that.
Well,
at any rate,
listen to,
um,
but that's not enough of that.
I'm glad everyone had a happy
Thanksgiving and I'm glad you're here.
What black Friday as you all know,
let's get to the real business,
which is today,
right?
Yeah.
Today's black Friday.
Oh yeah.
Good.
I got,
I got to appreciate this top light.
Like it's so amazing how the sandwich
and then like first of all you've got
this beautiful thick ass and then even
the hand and the top right.
Oh,
perfect.
It's just incredible.
I actually had an awkward moment with
this because a,
I was looking at my phone at
Thanksgiving and saw you tweet this and
I started laughing my ass off and
immediately my family like,
what are you laughing?
What are you looking at?
I would like,
I was like,
I don't really want to show you that.
Do you consider the picture of my boss?
Here you go.
You consider this open face sandwich,
not safe for work then I,
yeah,
that's why I was like,
to be honest it's a little lewd,
but that's fine.
It,
yeah,
that might have to be,
that might have to be switched.
Not Safe for work isn't very gross to
you and naked except my balls drip down
to the bottom of that toast for that.
Um,
J that James Bald double o seven.
You're,
you're alleging real dude.
See y Ella likes me.
So today's black Friday and there's a
tradition in America to stomp the face
of every grandma and the way of your new
ps four.
But I have to say this year we had a
mellow,
mellow year.
I didn't see any fights.
I didn't see any babies thrown across
walmart.
I didn't see any,
uh,
ambulances picking up 90 year olds,
nothing like that.
I think the stores have finally gotten
smart and it's more like the older
videos are surfacing again.
Yeah.
Cause we have our craving those uh,
yeah,
I noticed that.
Yeah.
There's all these slick guys on Youtube.
Just they re upload all the old shit and
they say Thanksgiving Black Friday,
fight 2018 and disable the comments and
then every year.
But there's no really juicy,
fresh a fight.
Memes.
I think enough people died and got
trampled.
When I watch those old videos,
I'm like my God,
how did they not they you need to have
order in your store.
But what we did find was some free.
So what I've got here is a little
segment called black Friday around the
world.
Yes.
Um,
here we go.
I've got USA,
Canada and Brazil.
How do you think this will go?
Let's start in the United States and see
what black Friday is like there.
This one,
I couldn't tell if it was from this year
because there's,
so again,
people are starting pretty calm leading.
Exactly.
Excuse me.
He thought,
doesn't it look like at night?
It just blows my mind.
Imagine him waking up at three M.
I mean we tried once,
but we didn't make it.
I mean,
this is your day off.
This is Thanksgiving Day.
You spend your day at 3:00
AM trying to find most of the sales on
line.
No.
Yeah.
You don't need,
I don't know.
Some places do these crazy in deals,
but it's like they're trying to start a
riot,
you know?
Yeah.
You got it.
We need to order Walmart.
Oh,
we're supposed to play the thing,
right?
Yeah.
You got to hit me with that.
Zach,
did Zach Know Walmart theme song?
Oh,
he does?
Yeah.
You guys met with that.
We thought this was good.
Everybody.
Yeah.
Well one my hey,
throw it up now.
Yeah,
that's right.
Absolutely.
For audio listeners,
there's just hoards of people grabbing
Kellan nearly in a riot.
You're of people jumping over escalators
from grabbing television lenders.
I mean,
there you have it.
There you have it.
So that is black fret.
You want to watch that Ila?
Yeah.
Not like we have anything better to do.
My favorite right now we are.
We are Walmart.
Yes sir.
Those everyone would lyrics.
Oh,
you serious?
And when you typed it and I love that.
Okay.
I guess a manager at Walmart wanted to
do a little hype video for their people.
They get excited for black Friday.
I think it was the day.
Yeah.
Has the best.
This has employee in the century.
Nobody gets paid enough to do this.
Now I kill myself.
That's right.
Uh,
we uh,
Walmart.
Yeah.
They just gave this guy a 25 cent raise.
He's all stuff.
Did he say he got blood on your face?
What?
I was thinking you have
blood on your face.
Is that what black Friday is for them?
Oh,
you're going to be be a cashier
some day.
Really dream.
Dream big.
What do you got on?
You're going to be a cashier someday.
You got blood on your face.
It would be,
oh,
you love this.
Okay.
Yeah.
You got blood on your face.
You love this place.
Really?
Because those images seem contrary.
Hmm.
You'll be a thing.
We did the one with the lyrics.
You're right.
We need this to cut it.
What's that one?
Youtube channel.
That d codes.
Lyrics.
Genius.
Genius though website.
We need a genius.
A on Walmart fights on analysis.
You,
you may be a cashier someday.
If you play your cards right at Walmart.
I want to hire two more times.
Give them a great,
I think this guy's doing this bullet
for,
I'm pretty sure this constitutes cruel
and usual
punishment and constitutional under the
United States law.
I love that quote.
That's great.
So here you have it.
Black Friday in America.
God bless these wonderful country here
we have black Friday and Canada.
It's,
it's crazy.
I love this orderly.
They're getting a round of applause.
That's fine.
Looks like congratulations on wasting
your holiday.
Well,
they're Canadians.
Look how wonderful this is.
It probably served coffee.
They're just walking in super orderly
and calm.
The employees are lined up and giving up
ground look like giving high fives and
then have a five.
Wow.
What a,
what a joy.
What a thrill.
Um,
you know what I was thinking,
I was watching that it just takes one
lunatic to start running and it sets off
that chain reaction.
No,
no,
no.
Probably.
Well,
you,
I think if one person from the bottom
started cutting and running a front,
that's it.
Full riot mode and America,
you got five of those from the beginning
and nobody ever had a chance,
but there you have it black Friday and
Canada.
And now finally,
as you all know,
Brazil is as a crime ridden country.
There's huge disparities of very rich
and very poor.
Lots of corruption.
It's a rough place.
So black Friday in Brazil,
as you can imagine,
there's going to be one of the craziest
things you ever see.
And so I warn people with young children
and who are sensitive to trigger
warnings to a divert their eyes from
this very graphic scene.
Black Friday and breasts here.
But I see it.
I got the mascot.
Some girl was,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
So they're,
all the employees are lined up at the
gate and they're about to start pounding
it to get everyone outside super
heightened.
When here we go,
they got a Dj by the sound of this.
They're pounding on the wall.
Get ready everybody.
Here we go.
Well,
it's going to come through shit
completely empty.
There's not a thing of person outside,
not even one single person out that
nobody's there.
Incredible.
I wonder how they missed this violated
or got in trouble for it.
Yeah,
we're going to get the monetize for
sure.
I find it fascinating that nobody peeked
outside.
You know what I mean?
I love how they're pounding on the gay
and there's got a Dj in the mascot,
not even one person got the memo,
not even one person.
So there you have it.
And Lou have anything interesting to
talk about this black Friday,
black Friday around the world.
And on the topic of Thanksgiving,
we are a very topical show.
If nothing else.
Barney at the Thanksgiving Day parade,
macy's Thanksgiving Day parade.
Excuse me.
Thank you though.
In 1997 was murdered.
So the lane gunned down by the New York
state police and we talk a lot here on
the show about police brutality.
Well this is police brutality.
Uh,
the worst I've seen
and a long,
long time.
So this is more of a,
a memorial
for Barney.
Oh,
this is amazing.
Actually.
So it was really windy winter day.
Um,
and the bar new flow,
just it
so out of hand.
This video reminds me of Gulliver's
travels then people,
oh yeah,
the rope over.
I'm in there trying to take him out.
Hi.
This is probably the most,
well,
the people on the ground.
I also barneys floating everywhere.
He's completely out of control and
people on the ground or wrestling.
It's almost like a dragon.
I feel like I'm watching a movie.
The logical battle I'm trying to like,
well,
a mythical beast.
Um,
let me skip to where it goes.
It's
real spicy.
The crowd is a balloon as they should
be.
This is,
you can see that people.
Oh Wow.
Why is that rope filling?
Everyone's dressed up at,
it's a bunch of young.
Oh,
I thought they were all ladies,
but they're just up is like gnomes or
something.
What's he going to hang it off?
Even literally got people just as gnomes
clinging onto ropes for dear life.
I mean,
it's incredible.
Hi,
this is the site of Santa's workshop
that we have not seen before.
The dressed is Barney.
Yeah.
Oh,
Barney's Barney.
Barney's holding I,
but they were known Stan.
Why can't they?
It could be no.
Ooh.
So I wonder if you would get mad and
then it splits.
Hawaii don't fit under the Gust of wind.
They fighting to quell
beast.
You're like a five year old.
You Love Barney music.
The audience is losing their mind
because this is the most exciting thing
they've ever seen in Thanksgiving Day
parade.
MMM.
You think you could get taken out if
that thing just tumbled into the crowd?
It's massive.
Probably.
Yes sir.
They fill those up with helium.
Is that what they do to make them flow?
My bad.
So yeah,
because it isn't a hillary,
I'm like a precious resource,
like a lot of helium.
I'm sure that pressures,
I've heard that it's a finite resource
that cannot be replenished.
So that was a good thing.
We're using it for important things.
Yes sir.
Barney Barney,
uh,
this is when it gets really violent.
And again,
I have to give a trigger warning here
for people.
We're sensitive.
The violent,
uh,
content because as you're about to see
the boys and black,
the police are about to make a violence
slang of this innocent bystander.
I mean,
what did Barney ever do except try to
entertain the kids in here?
He has been gun down,
taken down in cold blood.
I mean,
he's just a brother trying to live his
life.
You know what I mean?
Just trying to enjoy the parade.
Got It.
Bring the dinosaur down.
Humans always keeping the dinosaur down.
I mean,
God,
there's no justice in this world.
You know,
I need some human rights activists to
take a look at this foot.
Yes.
His body is splitting apart.
Yeah.
If you're a Barney lover,
this is got to be some traumatic
footage.
Yeah.
Okay.
Here come the police guys.
So again,
sensitive morning here,
here they come up with a foot.
They starting to stab him at the feet.
Please.
Oh,
oh,
this is,
I got,
I gotta commend these brave officers.
Honestly climb on top of that with a
knife.
That's pretty daunting.
Does it remind you of Goldberg traveled
like it seriously feels like they're
bringing down a dragon or some shit.
It's kind of mythical.
You're right.
Yeah.
And on the day of November 22nd,
1997,
the dragon was plain.
They decapitating him look out there,
cut again.
And their gap with dating goes,
where's Jesse Ventura?
Brutal.
Yeah.
Exciting.
I had never seen that before.
Kind of a thrill.
Kind of a joy on this beautiful
thanksgiving day either.
What do you know about thanksgiving?
Because you are an immigrant to this
country.
Uh,
you know nothing about no.
The Turkey.
Oh,
and you say thanks.
I think that's probably what most people
know about it.
You know,
we never said thanks at dinner.
That's true.
Should we do it now?
No.
It could be exciting.
What am I thankful for?
What am I truly thankful for?
Well,
clearly you.
MMM,
clearly I'm thankful for you and
everything good in my life was a result
of,
um,
I'm thankful for this is so long.
Yeah,
we want to do it,
but it's great,
isn't it?
No,
not good content.
I have a black Friday deal state you
might be thankful for.
Oh yeah,
let's try to segue out of this.
Um,
okay,
let's do that.
So go ahead.
He looked put together a segment for us.
I mean,
how exciting is this?
Although we own and you to open them.
Oh Shit.
Um,
it's three 30 food.
Take a break or do you want to do a
segment first?
Yeah,
we should.
Okay.
So when we come back from our break Ila
as put together black Friday deals that
nobody wants,
and there's some hilarious stuff on
here,
like the dollar tree,
everything's $1 today only.
And so much more today on the HV podcast
takes giving extravaganza,
uh,
as usual,
your stomach and the rest of your life
are at war.
You need to eat,
but you can't stop what you're doing to
deal with it.
And the only fast things that deliver
are not what you want.
I've had this problem all the time.
Your favorite restaurant doesn't
deliver?
Well now they do with postmates.
Yes.
The APP that adds a delivery option two,
your favorite restaurants.
But that's not all.
You forgot eggs,
milk.
No problem.
They'll go to the grocery store.
You want that tasty burger from your
favorite place,
no problem.
They'll go there even though they don't
deliver you looking even for a bottle of
wine or summer beer,
throwing a pack of smokes.
If that's your thing,
no problem.
They will do anything for you.
And it's so freaking convenient.
I cannot endorse postmates enough and as
they say,
it is your new longterm munchies booty
call.
Although a parent item went in.
Yeah,
don't try anything on your driver.
I don't think that's what that means.
Um,
I love postmates so much.
Just give it a shot and you're going to
see how fricking incredible and
convenient and mind blowing.
This APP is for limited time.
Postmates is giving you $100 of free
delivery credit,
so you get to try it for the first seven
days,
$100 free delivery credit.
Give it a shot.
You've got nothing to glues.
Start your free deliveries.
Download the APP to date and use code h
three that's code h three for $100 of
free delivery credit for the next seven
days.
Save the hassle.
Get the food you love fast at postmates
with code h three I love this app.
Please try it out.
Appreciate you.
I love that dollar Shave Club has
everything I need to look,
feel and smell my very best.
What I love the most is that I never
have to go to the store.
That's because dollar shave club
delivers everything I need right to my
Dang door and two,
they keep me fully stocked and what I
use so I don't ever run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready.
No matter what you're getting ready for.
They got you covered.
Head to toe for the hair,
your skin,
your face,
you name it,
they've got it.
And they have this new program where
they automatically keep you stocked up
on the products you use.
You determine what you want and when you
want it,
and it shows up right at your door from
once a month to once every six months
you decide.
That's what I love and let me tell you,
they got this new shampoo out that is a
beautiful,
perfectly bands.
It's got this beautiful smell.
It keeps my hair nice and lush.
Unfortunately I have no hair.
But before when I did have hair,
that little Pouf Mohawk in the middle
was so lush and beautiful and smelled
like a dream.
Fortunately it did not look good,
so I had to act it out.
But the smell and the feel unbelievable.
Plus what they're handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you say.
So right now they got a bunch of starter
sets you can try for just $5 dare you
find that deal in the grocery store like
their shower started set,
which includes the shampoo.
After that,
the restock box gets shipped regular
such products at regular price.
So what are you waiting for?
Get your starter set now for just five
dollars@dollarshaveclub.com
slash age three that's dollar shave
club.com/h
three guys get started today for just $5
hairs.
If you are in the market for a watch,
now is the perfect time to head on over
to Vince,
Sarah,
because they are having an epic pre
black Friday sale.
And that's right.
The biggest site wide sale of the year.
My Dude's the holiday can be stressful
enough without having to worry about
breaking the bank.
Vince Zero Watches is taking the hassle
out of holiday shopping by having an
applique pre black Friday sale.
No matter who you're shopping for.
You can get them a luxury beautiful time
piece that they will love long after the
holiday season is over as Isla is
beautifully modeling for you here.
And the best part is you can get it
early.
They're mission is great compelling
luxury time pieces with impeccable
craftsmanship to inspire as many people
as possible to elevate their game and
ultimately to lift her legacy.
My Dude,
you can live a legacy with this watch.
Holy smokes.
Um,
we learned that luxury is a process is
not about specs,
is not about price,
it's about marketing.
I,
it's not about marketing items to be
thrown around.
It's a matter of attention to detail and
a step by step process to craft every
product.
And especially it's about legacy.
They're big on legacy.
Um,
we wanted to offer a Washer,
was able to stand out,
get noticed,
and set yourself apart and not conform
and at an accessible price,
their watches have a distinct look,
a quality feel.
This watch will get you noticed and that
I mentioned legacy.
Oh,
able to provide the look and feel of
bold luxury watches at 10 times the
price by selling directly to the
consumer.
So if you want to capitalize on this
black Friday sale,
best prices of the year,
head on over to Vince,
Sarah watches.com/h
three sale or click the link and the
description,
um,
crew is happening right now and these
offers will not last long.
And let me,
let me be frank.
Your legacy won't last long either
unless you get this watch.
Thank you.
Welcome back.
My Black Friday dude's speaking of black
Friday.
Isla has put together segment of black
Friday deals that nobody wants and
nobody cares about.
Hilo.
I'm very excited.
You know,
why don't we switch spots?
So I prefer a few control though.
Okay.
No good.
What do you think to close?
Yeah,
I guess,
Whoa,
this is weird.
So first up we got it myself.
Ass Man,
not Ethan.
You might be interested.
Sure.
Um,
it's on a lower price right now.
Uh,
what's the discount?
Lower price of it.
You have to select the size.
I think
it's uh,
I can tell you it's about $5 off.
Well that's thrilling.
Oh yeah.
So there you have it.
I like with the abs are just kind of
built into it.
Sure.
Yeah.
You need help.
It's just called men waist trainer vest
for wait.
Oh,
it's for weight loss.
I feel like you could wear it.
It's just for instant weight loss.
Well instantly gives you abs by just
kind of faking weight loss hot.
And he'll print course set body shaper.
Oh,
it's a body shaper.
Zipper sauna tank top workout shirt.
Okay,
let me see it go up.
Two images.
Whoa.
Fire.
All right,
well that's all right.
It's actually got good reviews.
Let me read some of the room.
It's called,
it's in the category.
Sauna suits.
Yeah.
Oh.
Wolds pink.
We want to go in there.
What are you talking about?
Show it.
You have to show that picture.
Oh Wow.
So that's when you can look like that's
a great reality versus expectation.
But wait,
is it,
what is the purpose of it?
To just slim look slimmer?
I can't read it from here.
Oh,
he says,
no doubt about it.
It makes me sweat more than usual.
Well that's because you have a super
tight,
it doesn't allow you to ventilate a
shaman vendor one start.
Well,
either way.
This can be yours for $5 off.
A thrilling,
thrilling savings here today on black
Friday.
We're not hating here.
That's right.
Elan not hating.
Next is a horn porn horn.
Incredible.
Also very well reviewed.
A,
uh,
wait,
wait.
Is the sell price?
This was featured on their black Friday,
so it's not even,
not even save any money.
This genuine ox horn.
Well this was featured maybe.
All right,
well what are we going next one?
What do we got?
Tell me about it.
I don't know.
It's just if you want to look like
grades men,
12 inch authentic ox horn drinking
genuine leather.
Mm hmm.
And with the stand,
I guess it's on sale,
but we don't know for how much.
So hurry while supplies last.
Exactly.
It was exciting.
Wish we had some exciting music to play
over that.
Ramp it up.
Zack,
give us some thrilling music cause
timing.
Oh,
okay.
I think probably gets so dirty so quick.
My greasy hands on that day.
Not really.
Okay.
We've got an ogre.
Gramar wait,
is that world of warcraft?
What does,
oh Gramar is that a world of warcraft
reference you guys?
Uh,
Okra Mar is the Capitol of the,
uh,
the hoard,
so yes.
Oh,
so we have a world of warcraft march on
sale today.
I think it's spelled differently though.
Oh.
Gramar I don't think that that's wow.
I could be wrong.
You know what?
It's on sale today.
On this black Friday.
Get it while supplies last.
It's Auger Maher.
I'll gramar winter warm for wall
steering wheel cover with handbrake.
Oh,
the handbrake cover comps.
So you can match.
Yes.
If you're wondering,
the carpet does match the drapes.
That's right.
Yeah.
Okay.
This would be dangerous all.
Yes sir.
You live as oh,
grammar's always in constant threat of
invasion.
So is your safety in this car?
The nice stuff is probably the best
offer at the dollar tree.
Everything is actually a dollar once an
incredible sales black friday.com
that's right.
Wait,
are you saying that stuff at the dollar
tree isn't always a dollar?
That's right.
Again,
what?
It's a loophole and gray area that
somehow they managed to find that's
right.
Also advertising man.
Well,
I feel like inflation's got to the point
where now they just think if it's on a
dollar so clean,
like if it's one,
two,
three then they're like,
it's multiple of a dollars,
but today,
only today the dollar tree is actually
just $1 folks.
Egg credible savings.
This deal went live one month ago.
It says hurry while supplies last.
A thrill.
What a thrill it is to save on this
black Friday and you don't ever find
anyone in some gum.
CVS,
black Friday.
I'm on sale.
Incredible savings and 99 cents but
hurry while supplies last,
you have to be lined up at 3:00
AM to get these incredible pack of gum
for 99 cents.
Yes,
indeed.
Last but not list.
You need to upgrade your browser.
The one item we all need.
Wow.
Garth Brooks,
the anthology live part three.
Dog Park three is on sale today from
39 $30 to $17 the impala theology part
three.
Let's get physical while doing music.
How many disks is that?
Um,
it looks like five dancing for asking
and that steel high for this scarf.
Brooks,
I want to be cool.
I want to be slick.
That's right.
Yeah.
Head on over to a walmart slash ip slash
garth dash bridges darth anthology dash
live dashboard three ford slash
229-SIX-SEVEN-5895 while supplies last.
That's it.
Okay.
How's it failure I hit you with,
I know,
I know.
Incredible.
I think we may have sold a couple of
garth's broken anthology books I'm
buying right now.
And it's like stop live switching.
It's just on the long shot because he's
buying all these anthologies.
My resell these.
I like that.
And I do like that.
So the,
here's a story that I absolutely love.
Dude wants to legally change his h.
Why does he want to legally change his
days from 69 to 49 because it will help
him get more dates on tinder.
Oh my God.
Understandable.
At 69 69 that's right.
Here we have it here.
There's about a little video about it
because a legend man,
you just try to fuck.
He's like,
dude,
nobody wants to fuck a 69 year old.
Well my Dick,
I got a 49 year old.
Dick is still 69 we can 69 but I'm 49
and I,
I feel I suffer on the my age because
I'm much more younger.
Demos 68 so when I ask for a mortgage,
for example,
they say,
is it possible if I go on tinder?
You know,
I never thought about it that you can't
get a mortgage at all age cause you'll
die before he can pay it off.
Oh,
isn't that gnarly?
Wow.
I never thought about that.
Yeah,
this guy,
he's 49 you're could live,
but I guess they don't take the risks.
They're like,
did you want a mortgage?
You're 69 ish.
I'll give you five years tops the
mortgage bankers like you want a
mortgage?
I'll give you a 30 year
from 68 or 69 when the woman are there
and when I'm mocked in the,
you know the,
then they say,
okay,
then lie for your eight.
You say you are 49 I don't want to lie,
I want to be myself.
So don't force me to lie.
But when I am really 49 again,
I will have a baby again.
I will buy a new car again,
I will pay my house again.
I go outside and I invest my money again
because now I'm old man.
You know,
I have to save my money to give to my
kids so they can live.
But if I have that h
I have hope again,
I'm new again and there is the whole
future is there for me again.
All right.
Iron clad logic right there.
So I wanted to say,
well I,
I know there's been a lot of debate
about changing genders and this kind of
whole thing and that gender is a
construct,
a social construct and people changing
sex.
And all this,
you know,
we can debate about,
uh,
we can debate about gender roles and
that old things time however I think is
indisputable,
at least right now as far as we all
know,
time is a linear fact.
I don't think we're time traveling yet.
He's like,
he described himself as a young God is
he did you,
he said a 69 year old,
he's a positivity guru.
He says he does not feel his age and it
started a battle to make himself
illegally 20 years younger on the
grounds that he's being discriminated on
dating apps.
Doctors told him his body was that of a
45 year old man and he described himself
as a young God.
Yes,
that judge expressed skepticism,
but also noted that changing the sex on
a birth certificate as a transgender
people have the right to do that,
which was once impossible is now allowed
tension or people around the world have
fought long battles of the right to
change their birth certificates to match
their gender identity.
Where this is permitted,
the legal requirements vary in the
Netherlands.
Transgender people need a statement from
an expert affirming that they have a
purr,
permanent conviction that their gender
does not match what is on their birth
certificate and that they understand the
repercussions of their decision.
But again,
here,
you know,
that's uh,
gender is a kind of an abstract idea in
a sense that it's not a physical the
idea.
But here we're talking about age.
I mean
we can debate age,
right.
But apparently the judge is actually,
it's unlikely to happen,
but the judge is like open minded about
it too.
I mean,
what,
what does our world be when people
decide their own age?
Like a 13 year old or like an 18 old
being like I'm 20,
I am actually 21 it's an emotional age
and they call it an emotional age.
Dude,
what's wrong?
Uh,
imagine.
I you do it.
You know,
I like he,
oh,
he almost talks that if he was able to
change his age to like 45 that he'd be
like,
he's like my Dick will work again.
Yeah.
And like it will like magically like
actually reverses age.
I can get a mortgage,
my Dick will work there.
You have it.
What do you think?
You know that's a weird one.
He looks pretty good for 69.
I'll give him that.
Maybe he is a young God,
but you should embrace.
Hmm.
I think his problem is that would look
old for 49.
Yeah.
Dude,
that's 20 years and once you're that
old,
every decade is like hit you harder than
the last.
I think he's just like,
I don't want to fuck,
I don't want to fuck 69 year olds.
He's looking on tinder.
It's all these old ladies.
He's like,
I want to fuck these hot ass 49 year
old,
these four.
Have you seen these 49 year olds?
They're banging their hot as hell.
My Dick will work if I could only change
my age.
Uh hmm.
Do you think he really believes it or is
he,
is he full of Shit?
Well,
you had mentioned damn that it was some
what,
what?
Uh,
I,
it's hard to say.
All the articles I've read,
it seemed to take it very seriously.
But you've said that you had read
something that it's some kind of
protein.
Yeah,
I thought I had seen somewhere that
he's,
he's trying to,
um,
yeah,
I mean like you,
you brought up the whole gender issue
thing.
I think he maybe is trying to make a
point about that.
But yeah,
I mean like you said,
I mean obviously it's pretty fucking
difference session.
Awful.
Yeah.
You know,
I see people always trying to make this
my,
are you really gonna compare that to a
gender issue?
One is like measurably wrong.
Like,
okay,
you're by people who will say,
Oh,
you're bowling with the Dick.
That makes you a man.
But still you can identify more as a
female and so there's a debate to be had
and some empathy and understanding and
you can physically change your sex.
You can remove your penis and surgically
implanted vagina and you can assume the
identity of a female and you can be
born with a certain genitalia,
but it's kind of like in the middle.
What do you,
what do you mean,
like a peanut?
You can be both like an inverted u.
There are some people that are born with
both.
Oh yeah.
Or like stuff like that.
You know,
correct me if I'm wrong,
Dan,
but wasn't Jamie Lee Curtis born with
both a vagina and a penis?
I swear.
I swear,
look it up.
I'll look it up.
Jamie Lee Curtis,
super famous.
Uh,
uh,
she was like a babe.
She was like one of the hottest babes in
the 90s.
Let me make sure I'm saying her name
right.
Yeah,
that's her.
I think she was born,
uh,
with a,
with a both a penis and a vagina.
Uh,
that appears to just be an urban legend.
Are you kidding me?
Idiot.
Look again.
Double check that I just went to snopes
and they're,
they're falsing it just flat out so that
we fact check that I evidently,
there's a reason you thought that
though.
Cause this is like a thing.
Uh,
but this is not true.
I had never,
why would people think that about her?
That's so rare.
Yeah.
Homer.
But is that a real thing then?
Because now I'm questioning if that's
even,
yeah.
What,
what Ula was just describing.
Absolutely is a thing.
Sometimes it,
you know,
when a baby is born it's,
it's sort of ambiguous and it's sort of,
the doctor just kind of makes a call.
Um,
so that,
that is very low.
What does it mean?
A doctor just makes a call
literally that it can happen.
Wait,
no,
no.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
I got to understand this.
The doctor makes a call.
So is he doing something to the baby or
is he just breading?
Male or female and the birth
certificate.
The ladder.
And so what if the baby has a penis and
he's written down as female?
I,
I mean,
I don't know the specifics of it,
but I do know that this is,
I mean,
obviously this is not super common.
Wait,
I'm just really actually curious about
the metal.
Can you guys look into that period?
No,
I'm curious.
Let's look into that.
Um,
we're so sidetracked,
but I'm just fascinated by that.
So baby can be born with like either and
they cannot and the doctor can't tell
the genitalia.
Intersexuality occurs whenever human
being has both male and female physical,
correct characteristics.
Contrary to the main thing,
they do not have two sets of genitals.
They often have ambiguous genitals
structures.
Not readily identifiable was collectors
or penis or,
so it's somewhere in the middle.
Why?
But that means that they have like a Ho
like a vaginal,
like they have a vagina,
like an entrance and like a little penis
to,
does that mean they could actually fuck
themselves?
No,
no,
no.
I don't know.
I know,
I know you're just curious,
but yeah.
Um,
I'm asking what people are thinking
here.
We're in pursuit of knowledge.
I just,
I don't know.
I'm still reading.
I don't want to,
I don't want to misrepresent this at
all.
But anyway.
Well,
regardless of,
uh,
regardless,
Jamie Lee,
curtis,
he's not,
we have definitely cleared that one up
so
damn by,
it can be like,
eh.
Well,
at any rate it says that you can go in
and like people can go on a long periods
of their lives without knowing that they
were intersex
quiet and then they like grow out of it.
No,
just I think just when you're a kid,
I mean,
you're not necessarily seeing other
people.
You don't know that you're different.
I'm curious
to see what that looks like.
Obviously I can't show that.
Yeah,
no,
but I am curious.
But anyway,
that is,
why are you seeing pictures?
No,
I'm just trying to read about it.
But that's why the gender issue is like,
whoa.
Even though regardless of
that,
I,
that's such a stupid,
well,
people have been making these arguments
for so long.
People have been saying it about
homosexuality first they say,
Oh,
if two dudes can fuck each other or
marry each other,
then what?
Then what can we start marrying animals?
Yeah,
that's,
well,
it's,
it's just so weak.
It's so lame.
Like Adam,
first of all,
animals cannot consent.
You know,
people,
people always ask me,
can vegans,
um,
take a,
can they,
can you come?
And the vegans mouth people are always
asking you that.
People always ask me that.
No,
I did get an email about that.
Um,
but I,
I would say,
yes,
you can come and a Vegan smells and I'll
tell you why.
Because a human can consent to give you
their semen and I assure you that it
will be given with much pleasure if I,
my experience is any indication of that.
But animals cannot consent to give you
there.
Am I right Dan?
Am I representing this rate?
You're,
you're a vegetarian.
Well yeah.
Animals cannot consent to,
um,
allowing you to kill them or I guess
you're talking more about like dairy or
eggs or something like that.
Uh,
yes.
Correct.
Right.
So,
so semen is Vegan if you have the
consent of persons who you're sucking.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
um,
did you send me a link?
You want me to read this?
So back to that previous thing.
Um,
I just want to correct that.
It could look like a male or female
genitalia isn't look weird necessarily,
but you are homeless.
Could be,
Eh,
oh.
Like you could have the other hormones.
So sometimes that's the only during
puberty.
Interesting.
You'll feel different than the gender
that was given.
I'll show my screen,
I'm looking up in her s intersects
genitals.
Damn.
Okay man.
But they said that it happened actually
a lot more than people realize.
One in 100 people in the u s want.
That's what I had heard too.
I didn't want to say it just off the top
of my head and be wrong.
But yeah,
it's um,
it's much more common than
here's a picture of a,
I've typed intersects genitals and
here's a picture of Jamie Lee Curtis.
I swear to God,
they're definitely appear.
I guess that was an urban legend that
existed because many articles came up
about it when I googled it.
So I don't know how I'd never heard that
before.
It's just,
I heard that like,
as,
as like a fact.
False.
Uh,
let's see here.
Yes.
Is She,
she's a sheet.
But regardless,
I find that that argument very listen,
homosexuals,
transsexual,
there are people,
I just don't understand the whole,
this whole campaign of like trying to
why our,
why,
why are you even trying to contradict
them?
Just let them live their live like,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean obviously some of them are pretty
aggressive and annoying.
Well,
there's extremes in that.
Exactly.
You know,
but if someone's just like,
Hey,
I'm transgender,
I don't see that being an argument,
you know?
But again,
if this guy is doing it as a protest,
I think it's very,
very,
very weak because time is measured.
My Dude,
you have been on this earth for 69 years
and unless I missed a memo,
we do not have time travel yet.
And so time as I know,
no it is not yet in dispute.
Sexuality however,
is somewhat of an abstract concept.
I know that there are male and female
genitals,
so there is that concreteness of
biological sex.
But I guess what the Trans people talk
about is gender,
which is,
which is different and,
and,
and like we just said,
I mean even the,
even the biological aspect isn't it?
I mean it definitely is a completely
different beast.
So if he is trying to do this to make a
point,
it's a,
it's a pretty weak argument.
So weak argument.
And also,
I mean,
dude,
just,
just fuck those old ladies to be like
Kyle,
the Cougar Champs got no problem,
man.
He gets and he takes it for all of us.
He's a young man and you are trying to
lie on tinder about your age so you can
fuck some 49 year old,
cute little cuties,
young cuties.
Hmm.
It's fucked up,
man.
It's fucked up.
It's just not right there.
You have it.
They should be podcast spreading
knowledge.
This is a wild story.
So this American missionary who's trying
to spread the word of God goes to a,
uh,
there's an island in a,
in India that is blocked off from all
hue of humanity.
And this tribe has lived there in
isolation for 55,000
years.
Some people estimate and the Indian
government protects this island because,
well,
first of all,
I think there's something beautiful
about,
um,
they don't want any,
they don't wash.
Yeah.
And,
and I think there's something beautiful
about conserving that and just letting
them live in peace.
There's been,
people have attempted to go there and
they've always reacted violently as,
I guess I was reading an article that,
um,
the British,
a British went to the island early
during their colonial days and like
decimated the population of the island.
And since then,
their original numbers have been
decimated and now they're still just a
small fraction of what the population
was.
And they're very guarded,
justifiably from outsiders.
And so this American missionary goes to
India.
Let me pull up this article.
He writes that he's going there for
tourism,
but its real purpose is that he wants to
spread the message of Jesus and he knows
is going against the law.
Preventing.
Yes,
Indiana.
Go there.
India prohibits,
uh,
prohibits visitors,
um,
and well,
he was killed by the natives.
Yeah.
Let me read.
Whoops.
Um,
let's see here.
John is said to have died and a hail of
arrows as he set foot on North Sentinel,
sentinel island,
part of the Indian controlled islands in
the Bay of Bengal.
People live there or one of the few
tribes completely cut off from the rest
of the world and have previously fired
at outsiders.
The media here is really incredible and
these people are fascinating.
Like here's someone off the coast,
here's the,
um,
the tribe.
Yeah.
Like when they see people off the coast,
they stand guard on the beach.
They're fucking cool.
It's amazing what a trip.
It's like really?
Um,
here's the island right here.
So really beautiful little cuddle land.
Um,
this is incredible.
55,000
years they've been there.
Um,
Indian police confirm the death and said
local electronic engineers.
Simply,
his name was Alexander.
Uh,
he had locals and five fishermen took
him out to the island illegally.
Um,
he hired fishing a guys to get close and
he kayaked to the island from the boat.
Here's some more footage of them.
And this was like a known thing that
they were hostile,
prohibited by the Indian government.
They're known hot.
Well,
the fishermen knew that too.
And actually they're under arrest now.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
right.
Cause I mean,
they broke the law,
taking him there.
He was attacked by arrows.
But continued walking,
but I'm not,
the fisherman saw the tribals trying to
rope.
Oh my God.
The fisherman saw the tribals tying a
rope around his neck and dragging his
body.
They were scared and fled,
but return next morning to find his body
on the seashore fucking crazy.
Um,
the people are banned from getting
within three miles of the island.
The island with an estimated population
of between 40 and 200.
Wow.
That's not a lot family.
They used to be thousands of them and
said to be at risk of death if they have
contact with outsiders because they have
no immunity to common diseases like
fluent measles.
So this guy out there trying to give
them God.
Yeah.
Trying to get my little tastes at Ge is
us could actually end up,
um,
decimating them out the final,
I mean,
not a happy that guy died,
but it's like,
yeah,
you're God.
You got what?
Well,
you know,
I mean the guy went looking for Jesus
and he found him.
Okay.
Yup.
May have taken all,
he may have taken the whole veggies.
What he's like,
Hey,
he sees him in the afterlife is like,
I saved you all.
We made it.
We made it you guys.
On the evening of 14 November,
the group of six pretending to be
fishing evaded,
the patrolling police coast guard and
navy ships reaching the island at
midnight before Mr Chu Kayak to the
island in the morning,
please said the fishermen agreed a time
and place to meet each other near the
island.
On the morning of 17th November,
they saw a dead person being buried at
the shore,
which from the silhouette of the body,
clothing and circumstance appeared to be
the body of John Allen Choo.
This is an iconic photograph taken from
a helicopter after the 2004 tsunami,
which apparently a day somehow survive
like this huge tsunami that this guy is
shooting a bow and Arrow at a helicopter
because they're just so unacquainted
with the outside world.
I can't imagine what they would think.
What would you even think?
Yeah,
yeah.
Be Terrifying.
Some gnarly bird,
rightly.
MMM.
In a situation like this too.
I mean,
what,
what was the plan?
I mean,
how are you going to,
you can't just give them bibles,
they don't speak English,
obviously wanting to explore and Tati he
could be the one guy that could reach to
them.
So the thing about these missionaries,
they believe that it comes from a good
place,
even though it's insane as they think
that the best thing you can do for
another person is give them Christianity
because they'll die.
And internal torment trying to save.
He's just trying to save their soul.
Right?
So to him,
he's like,
this is like,
I'm going to save these guys from an
from eternal torment.
They never even got the word of Jesus
Christ.
So how are they supposed to get saved?
And so he goes out there with the purest
of intentions.
But I mean,
I will say for him at least he didn't
fuck a kid.
That's so bad joke.
So there is some thing nice to say about
him after all.
Mm.
Um,
it's pretty wild story though going too.
I mean he,
he clearly,
he knew what he was getting stuff into
cause he hired a black,
a black market,
uh,
illegal fishermen to write his ass there
and Kayak.
And of course,
according to what I read,
He,
there was hails of arrows coming at him
and he continued to walk with Bible in
hand.
It say that.
Yeah,
it's it.
Do you want me to go back?
I'll read that shit.
I think it's,
and we're in those,
it's Santa.
I'll read the hell out of that shit
again.
Okay.
Mel Gibson could make a movie about this
guy and in the movie the natives are
Jews.
Of course I'm here.
It says,
uh,
he was attacked by Arrows but continued
walking.
The fishermen said it's pressing
forward.
Yeah,
a little brave heart moment.
Um,
so there you have it pretty wild man.
Z American.
He's American.
Yes.
There you go.
What do you think about that?
I mean,
it says John loved people and he loved
Jesus.
It was willing to give his life to share
Jesus with the people in North Center.
No island ever since high school.
And John wanted to go to that island to
share Jesus with indigenous people
or since high school.
So it was like a longterm project for,
yeah,
I mean it's,
again,
I know that was kind of terrible state,
but it's really hard to sympathize with
this guy.
It's like you knew,
you knew exactly what you were getting
yourself into.
You know?
That's an interesting story.
At what point it's like you can go to
church and all that,
but at what point,
at what point does a religion become
insane?
Like you can believe in the person is
insane,
but his defining characteristic is that
he loved the God and that his whole life
was to go,
it's a,
it seems like a suicide then a little
bit.
Yeah.
It was a martyr,
right?
It was a mood or you know,
God loves martyrs,
so
there you have it.
Like you said though,
I mean the point where it,
it drips into,
yeah,
it's just fucked up,
is that there is the high likelihood
that you're going to affect all these
people with measles or smallpox or
something and wipe them out.
It's like,
that's a nice,
you're kind of,
yeah,
you're kind of fucked up at that point.
Well,
he's like my only,
I just wanted to get them a bible now if
they all die,
it's okay right there saying,
boy,
I don't think so dude.
They're all safe.
No,
I dug a little bit of arrogance little
bit,
but I feel bad for the guy.
I wish them all the best in the
afterlife.
IOP is received well by God and that he
says you did my work and you save those
savages,
you know?
I mean,
my God,
they've got bows and arrows.
They need bibles and we need to get them
jobs so that they can pay their 15% tiff
teeth.
How do you say that when the tight
tight,
but we need to get those savages pink
tight right now because you know that,
okay
God,
don't run on faith.
You run a money.
All right,
what's next?
Wow.
We got a lot of,
a lot of windows open,
you know,
speaking of stories that I don't know
how to feel about it too.
There was another one 95 year old Nazi
deported to Germany and I found this so,
such a fascinating story because I one
hand,
here's a shit head Nazi,
which we all,
hey,
um,
but he's like this 95 year old guy who's
being deported to Germany.
He's lived here for 70 years.
He's 95 here is in the u s yeah,
in the United States.
1949.
Um,
and Germany doesn't want them either.
They're like,
he's not a city.
We don't fucking want this Nazi,
but he's so old and frail.
Uh,
well let me watch the video.
Do you ever night up in New York man,
officials are calling the last surviving
Nazi great jacket.
Like he's 94 year old.
Can't handle like her.
What the hell you could take out a,
he could gas.
Did you at any minute and so weird.
1949 hiding his past as an armed guard
and don't think it was right.
He was stripped of his citizenship years
ago,
but he remained here in the u s that is
until now.
[inaudible] Mary is here with a story.
Tara,
good morning.
Good morning,
Paula.
Yeah,
Paul.
He has been living in the shadows for
decades.
Amat Authority say is the last known
surviving Nazi collaborator on US soil
until now,
living in Queens,
New York.
His presence,
they're bringing on year the outrage
from the surrounding community,
but this morning he's been deported to
Germany at the direct order of president
trump.
ABC News was there exclusively as ice
agents wield no.
At 95
die like that's it.
Get the Germany and what you can't gave
him and get on a plane at 95 I mean that
guy is going to not last long.
Well,
Jeremy doesn't know what to do with them
either,
but I guess the premise is that he's a
Nazi and he doesn't even,
the guy deserves no dignity or comfort
or anything.
Right.
That's,
I guess the premise they sent ice out
there for Christ's sake to wrap them up
and throw him in a airplane.
Well here.
Oh,
so you a Nazi.
You're watching him is on the case.
Five year old navy.
Listen to Justin Bieber.
Is there,
do you have any comment?
Do you have any comment on Ariana
Grande's breakup with a Pete,
Pete Davidson?
Sir,
are you a Nazi?
Yes sir.
Have you heard?
Thank you.
Next,
do you have any comment sir?
Jerry Seinfeld is,
I'm one of the most rich Jews.
Have you seen his standup?
Are you fan of Jerry Seinfeld?
Sir,
can I get a,
can I get a remark?
You don't believe it looks like he's
dead,
sir.
Sir.
Are you fan of Seinfeld and Larry?
David,
have you seen Seinfeld the show,
sir?
Love it.
I mean,
it's obviously a theater.
It's like a show cause nothing's really
at stake here.
It's just like a statement.
It's a statement.
It's a theatrical.
It's fair.
It's very much just for Shell.
Okay.
But what do you learn later in the
stories that he was just a guard.
I don't know what his involvement was
necessarily an n and the execution of,
of people during the Holocaust.
He was a guard at one of the death camps
though,
right?
Yes,
he was.
And He,
Oh yeah.
Well here,
this story continues to explain,
but the real question is,
um,
what does he think about,
uh,
the full house remains
okay.
It's finally being deported for his
alleged role as an armed guard is a Nazi
death camp at the whole in decades after
his alleged involvement.
I never regret,
sir.
Do you have any regrets?
Justice Department investigators?
Sure.
Have you seen the movie
any regrets
that's complicit in the deaths of
thousands of Jews during World War Two?
Authority?
Say Paul,
he lied to immigration officials when he
first entered the u s in 1949 and it
wasn't until 2003 that he was exposed as
an alleged war criminal and stripped of
his US citizenship.
Anything you'd like to say,
sir?
Anything delete investigators.
Think right
sir?
Have you seen frazier?
Do you know that Fraser is run by Jews?
Do you have any remark?
This footage is so weird.
Caring and willing.
That one.
Then this,
I'm confused about the straight jacket
situation.
Yeah.
This tray Jack.
I see a clear and eminent threat,
sir.
And in 2004,
what do you think about crusty being a
juicer?
Have you seen the Simpsons [inaudible]
who was a Jew in the that yeah.
His Dad was a rabbi.
I'm a deep,
I got Simpson's Laura for days.
Okay.
During a single nightmarish day in
November,
1943 all of the more than 6,000
prisoners of the Nazi camp that Yucky
Pauli had garden.
We're systematically butchered.
A judge ordered him to port it in 2005
but no country would take him for years.
Protestors gathered outside his home in
Queens,
demanding action.
Members of Congress imploring president
trump to finish what was started to send
a message to the entire world that the
United States stands firmly against
antisemitism,
bigotry,
and hatred.
The deportation drawing rare praise for
trump from top democrats.
War Criminal.
He didn't deserve to live in the United
States.
He doesn't deserve to die in the United
States place of freedom.
Mini quality where we respect each
other's different
sources.
Tell a B,
c news.
The president became fixated on the case
ordering his new ambassador to Germany,
Richard Grinnell to make polys and
deportation a top priority.
After being sworn in.
It's unclear what's next for him.
He's being detained by the German
government,
but they're still evaluating as legal
status since they don't consider him to
be a German citizen.
So deported overnight future to be
determined in Germany.
Exactly.
Hi everyone.
George.
Stephan,
how about that?
Oh,
it's a weird one.
It's a weird one.
I mean he's a Nazi shit bag,
uh,
clearly,
but he's also 95 years old.
You know?
What would you do?
Well,
I mean,
I don't know how to feel about it.
I'm [inaudible],
I'm ambivalent.
I just don't see at this point what's
the point of doing this?
Yeah,
they should just throw him in a hole.
I'm in prison.
Hmm.
Sounds like you know,
just the whole,
it sounds like since it took this long
for them to report him and Germany
doesn't want him either.
He basically is probably just going to
spend the rest of his life in,
in a camp.
Kind of ironic.
Yeah.
That is kind of a beautiful thing.
Let's put them in a camp.
I'm okay with it.
You go make them watch a b movie for all
of eternity.
Oh,
fate was Jerry Seinfeld presents to the,
yeah,
but up everytime that speeds up every
time it says be.
Yeah.
Let's hop on over to fat submissions.
Guys,
if you have submissions for us,
questions,
videos,
suggestions,
anything at all,
please drop us a
line@podcastaththreehthreeproductions.com.
Today we have an email from Ma Meechi
guys,
big fan of the show.
Oh,
this is,
sorry,
I'm getting ahead of myself.
You want to watch the CEO of Papa John.
Now let's go to this fancy finishes.
Yeah.
Boy.
Michi says,
I think Honestly Ping in the sink is a
superior method than using a urinal.
Pros,
you can save up to five liters of water
because you don't have to flush.
You can wash your hands while you're
doing it.
I don't understand.
Don't,
don't you finish pain before you wash
your hands.
Otherwise,
what's the point?
None of this makes sense.
Why are you washing your hands while
you're paying?
That's you're not done with the act.
The sink doesn't.
Have you ever thought about,
you haven't thought about this,
but I washed my hands before Ip cause I
don't want to get my dick dirty.
Right.
Makes Sense.
Because the Dick has kind of a holy,
it's my temple.
It's a uh,
it's a quarantine down there.
Uh,
the sink doesn't really get dirty
because you are cleaning it up while
you're paying literally impossible to
miss.
So you don't have to worry about
cleaning up or even putting toilet seat
up.
Splash it.
Just something that I'm concerned about.
It says not cleaning it up,
but if you're paying in a sink,
there's a little drops of urine all over
the place.
Standing Upright.
Cons,
you have to properly clean the sink once
a week.
That's disgusting Bro.
Once a week,
if somebody walks in on you,
you are going to get kicked out of their
house.
Um,
well I,
I disagree with the premise of peeing in
the sink,
but I found a subreddit called sync
pisters on know,
which is singularly,
there's a whole subculture.
Yeah.
It's a whole community dedicated to the
glory of paying in a sink and from the
sidebar that says,
don't ask yourself what the world needs.
Ask yourself what makes you come alive
and go do that.
Because what the world needs is people
who have come alive.
He was talking about pissing in the
sink.
One P is sterile.
Two sinks are unsterile.
Three people spit in the sink every day
and occasionally vomit there.
I don't pee and my friend seek,
I don't pee in the kitchen sink.
I run the water while Ip.
Uh,
I never shit in the sink.
Well,
that's a good,
I don't pee in the sink when they're a
year olds nearby.
I don't pee in the tub unless I'm
showering in it.
If I noticed that NEP has missed the
drain,
I wipe it down.
Well,
I right off the bat,
but the P is sterile thing.
I'm believe that's bullshit.
I know that gets repeated on you.
Look that up because I recently saw an
article saying that p is not actually
sterile.
It's way PA's gross.
Okay.
These gross,
we can all agree with that.
Although I've seen some porns.
Where do people don't think it's gross?
I'm sure you can find everything is not
stale.
Stale or stare.
It could be stale I suppose,
but it's not sterile.
I keep the water running after I finish
peeing,
peeing in the sink.
Although more readily accomplished,
my mail is not in any way limited to the
mail.
Sex.
Now here's one of the posts that I
looked at that really horrified me.
Okay.
Which goes against the tenants of peaks.
If this goes against the tenants of sync
peers,
and this is the fourth highest rated
post on the subreddit.
So God a different kind of mile high
club.
That dude is peeing in the sink and an
airplane toilet right there.
This has gotta be ironic.
Well,
this is people for real.
I think it is for real.
Should,
um,
although it's hard to say it because the
post under it says heavy breathing and
it's a picture of a sink.
Slash.
Gear.
We were gang owned and see that one.
Yeah.
Imagine pissing in the sink.
Piss her master race.
What is this?
Imagine paying,
but you have to flush it.
This meme was made by Cinque p gang.
All right,
well there you have it.
So I,
I think you should use a toilet,
dude.
If you're asking me,
I think he should use the toilet.
You know,
you may enjoy it and I'm,
I've peed in a sink before.
I'm not going to lie.
Okay.
I've done it,
but I don't,
I've not made that one.
I think it was possibly that the which
sink.
I think it must have been first when I
was a kid,
just out of curiosity.
And then another time probably,
I don't remember if it was with you,
Elo or different girlfriend,
but we were both in the bathroom at a
time and she was on the toilet and I
peed in the sink.
It may have been with you.
You remember something like that?
Yeah,
I think it was you.
It was a long fucking time ago.
That must've been like so long ago now.
Boy.
Like super drunk.
Yeah.
I think we were drunk.
I think it was like an art gallery and
we were drinking wine or some shit.
But regardless.
No,
it wasn't at home.
we were drunk right off.
But the point is that yes,
we weren't thinking right.
It's not like something we would do.
No.
And I was,
I cleaned up.
I didn't splash,
but I also,
I'm just saying a splash could happen.
Splash does happen.
And all I'm saying is that why of it
too.
At brush next to the sink.
There was no toothbrushes next to the
sink and Bob,
this guy.
Oh yeah,
no.
Well,
you know,
they say that there's poop particles
found on most toothbrushing or you said,
I'm telling you,
look it up.
Damn.
We're fact checking who particles found
on most toothbrushes.
But I think that life is complicated
enough.
You don't need to be paying and sinks
looking over your shoulder.
Try explaining that to a,
you know,
a new date or a family member or God
forbid anyone.
I mean the,
uh,
the poop thing is verified and can looks
like.
Thank you.
Who doesn't know their shit?
Now you,
me an excerpt,
Dan.
Well,
it says I'm your toothbrush is home to
plaque,
blood and even fecal matter.
Yes.
You're probably scrubbing poop particles
all over your pearly whites.
There was a study in 2012 this,
this sink piss.
There's listening are like,
so that's the problem with is again the
sinker,
right?
I say don't pee in the sink for Christ's
sake,
man.
Get your shit together.
Chris Donahue,
what up h three fairly popular men style
video,
uh,
made a video about youtubers with Wac
hairstyles and to no surprise.
Thank you.
Ethan was one of the people he talked
about.
Here we go buckle up.
I'm ready to get pissed off.
And last but certainly not least,
the fourth tip or the tear,
I mean that with love,
but he looks like an Elf.
Ears are a little pointed.
It's true.
It's like the hair,
everything he's got going on.
He's very happy.
He's very elf.
Handsome health chic style.
It's the AIRINC still.
He's a little bit of a swashbuckler.
Okay.
You know,
pirates wore gold earrings to pay for
their funeral.
Is that real?
Dan?
Can we fact check that I'm on it.
Linkedin has an all the fire.
It's a war gold earrings so that if they
died in combat,
they,
Erin could be used to pay for their
funeral.
Is that fascinate you?
I did not hear that.
Well,
I'm a wealth of knowledge and Dan is
fact checking me as we speak meanwhile,
but could be so much better is Mr.
Ethan Klein.
Ethan has incredibly thick,
coarse curly hair.
He's gone short.
He's gone long.
He's gone.
Throw another one of those you'd Zippers
that I absolutely love and it definitely
you're hitting needed more tlc then he's
coming.
Or Hot Dude like lists.
Who wouldn't fuck the shell?
Legless the blonde.
Yeah.
Isla you fucked the show.
Like list.
Yeah,
you would.
You know who legless is dating Katy
Perry.
Really?
Wow.
It's getting some fucking premium.
That's what I meant by Elf now that I
found out you liked my content
giving it.
Now the incredible thing about Ethan and
his hair is so crazy because it's crazy
curly.
One of the problems with thick coarse
currently
bomb hairstylist.
I would totally hire him to be my
hairstylist
hair is that if you don't understand it,
if you don't nurture it and love it and
get a hairstyle is that understands how
to cut it and it can be a disaster,
but it could be better like this with
the right product.
Yeah.
What's happening here?
What happened here,
Dan
am I asked him,
Oh fuck,
but certainly not least the fourth
popular.
You could be better like this with the
right problem.
When you that Dan,
what does it,
what the fuck is that shot?
It's just the screen got super small.
Can you help me out here?
I think so,
but how could he missed that?
What the hell?
Youtube helped me out.
That could be better like this with the
right there.
What is this?
Are you seeing Miss Dan?
Yup.
I'm seeing it.
Is it not just baked into his video and
he just fucked up.
I mean it's just so strange but okay.
Product,
the right kind of,
that guy's got some hair.
You think I can pull that look off
field?
I think you could buy your winner and
take some work.
That guy's got like wax in his hair.
You know what I mean?
I do.
I draw the line at wax,
but that's hot hair.
I mean,
that hair's fucking,
maybe it's just they rocket.
I think it's just that he's very
attractive and it looks like,
it looks like someone just here will
look good on that guy.
That guy could have like pubic hair and
looked pretty good.
I want to fuck this guy's what I'm
saying?
This hair.
Come on dog.
There's no way in hell I'm selling my
hair like that.
I mean,
I'm not knowing that he's got a fade in
like a little pompadour curl.
I mean,
dude,
imagine a Chubby guy like me who dresses
in like elastic waist shorts,
walking out their haircut like that
curly,
luscious locks of amazingness.
Come on,
dude.
I am.
There's no way I'm styling my hair like
that.
What do you think?
You know,
you like my hair the way it is.
Yeah.
I like it longer.
Peewee Herman.
Yeah,
girl,
let's go jerk off in a movie theater
like this.
You think I should go see a stylist who
understands curly hair?
He might need some type of relaxer or
Keratin treatment.
Just to take a little bit of the curl
out of the hair.
It's going to relax the curl a little
bit more in terms of product.
He could probably get away with the Pete
and Pedro Cream,
which is a leave in conditioner or the
beat and Pedro paste that he's looking
for a little bit more.
Pedro.
Sure.
This guy's,
this guy's
pedro money.
Oh Wow.
He calls it the question.
Everything he says he's brand new.
He's in their pocket.
You think it's his
right and a little bit of shine.
Gentlemen,
if you are not sure what
well there you have it.
Um,
I think you should go for it man.
Well,
I'm going to have to wait like a year
before all your hair.
Yeah,
that's true.
As long again,
but when that happens,
I'm going to ask.
Yeah,
boy.
For some Pete and Pedro,
whenever it was he selling.
This one comes from James.
Hi,
my name is James.
I'm from the UK and a level 10 vapor.
Dan will know what I mean.
Am I little bit sick?
That's a high,
that's a high level.
Is that good?
Oh yeah.
And my local shop,
I found what I swear is a budget hunk
version of Ethan.
Maybe it's just me.
Let's see.
Yeah,
it's a vape juice.
There it is.
Yeah.
Oh definitely.
I was like,
wait,
what happened over here?
He continues.
Just thought you should know.
It kind of tastes like shit.
There was a lemon and lime flavor
available.
Tilt.
Keep doing what you're doing and
congrats on the baby.
It definitely looks like a budget.
It looks like animate and so me.
Well you know what,
if you're going to use my likeness for
vape flavor,
at least make a nice one,
you know?
Yeah.
That's bogus that it's a terrible
flavor.
I wonder what it sells for on Black
Friday.
If I can get this one discount.
Probably always on discount.
I'm going to try and track some down.
I want smoke.
You vape.
Yeah.
So there you have it.
That is all we've got today.
Um,
hope y'all have a wonderful Thanksgiving
weekend.
I'll be all had a great thanksgiving.
Thanks for joining us here today.
Next Friday.
We've got bill wirtz finally coming in.
I'm super excited to have him.
Um,
Oh yeah,
Jack and Eric.
Is that the week after Dan?
I believe so.
The boys are back in town the week after
that.
I'm very excited.
A lot of time.
And um,
I'm super excited to meet bill words.
I'm such a huge fan of all,
very high and he's such a mysterious guy
too.
Just so creative and interesting,
dude.
So if you have questions or anything
you'd like to ask him,
or you want to tell me anything about
them,
head on over to the sub reddit.
There's a thread there where you can
submit a lot of great questions in there
already too.
Awesome.
That's great.
Thanks for participating in that.
So make sure to tune in a week from
today for Bill Wirtz.
Meanwhile,
have an awesome weekend and we love Ya
and wish you all the very fricken best.
Thanks for watching.
Bye.
You.